hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
bunch of Batman vs. Superman stuff
that's been going on
mostly Emily Blunt supposedly becoming
the new Catwoman as well as Lex Corp and
you know head-shaving talk and Justice
League so I'll be doing a breakdown of
all that but if you're finding me for
the first time I'm just doing more big
movie videos this summer be sure to
subscribe to get everything I try to
split the week between Marvel's Star
Wars DC but feel free to leave me
suggestions for other big movies you
want me to do so Emily Blunt is
literally killing it right now and edge
of tomorrow and she's been rumored for a
lot of big superhero roles over the
years so we should totally not be
surprised that she's being considered
for the new Batman vs Superman movie
she's had a long history of almost being
big characters like Black Widow and
Christopher Nolan's version of the
Catwoman but here's some details on that
and where the character would fit into
the movie so here is what's actually
happening right now she is meeting with
Warner Brothers about the movie if she
did join up she'd have to sign up for
the entire franchise because obviously
the character would be featured in
Justice League and any future sequels
she hasn't been cast yet officially
she's just the biggest person they're
talking to right now and quick sidenote
she has met with Marvel about a mystery
project - rumored to be Miss Marvel
she's one of those eight lists actresses
that fits really well into these big
movies so anytime one comes along she
gets considered for a role there's
actually two parts to this Catwoman news
first it was originally supposed to be a
small part that was a romantic interest
for Ben Affleck's Batman but because
they chose to upgrade the movie to a
Justice League prequel and started
teasing all these other big characters
everyone's thinking that they've changed
that small character into a much larger
part thus Catwoman so like I said she
was originally up for the part of
Christopher Nolan's Catwoman but lost
out to Anne Hathaway not because she's a
bad actress just because Christopher
Nolan felt like Anne Hathaway served his
version of Catwoman better so whenever
they shook everything up at Warner
Brothers and combined the Batman and
Superman movie universes Emily Blunt got
kicked back into the system movies had
big characters like this all the time
and cut them out at the last minute it
actually happened to shailene woodley in
spider-man 2 she was originally playing
Mary Jane they shot footage with her but
then cut her out at the last minute just
because they already had too many
characters so until you see Catwoman on
screen in this Batman vs Superman movie
take all this news
the grain of salt if you do want to see
what Emily Blunt looks like whenever
she's kicking ass go see edge of
tomorrow this weekend
Catwoman's a totally different character
but a lot of times it helps whenever you
see actors doing other big action movies
so I know a lot of you are asking you
know how the hell is this Batman vs.
Superman movie gonna work when they're
creaming all these characters into the
same movie all these really big
characters well it's likely that they're
just gonna give really small parts to
those secondary characters and then give
them larger parts when we get to Justice
League in the future sequels so yeah
there's gonna be a ton of big characters
but most of them you're not gonna see
that often at least in this first Batman
vs. Superman movie personally I'm a fan
of Emily Blunt so I'm bummed that she
didn't get to be Black Widow or
Christopher Nolan's Catwoman but I also
like Anne Hathaway and Scarlett
Johansson too so I wouldn't change
anything if given the chance we have to
remember though if blunt ends up
becoming part of this Justice League
franchise she's probably not gonna get
to be Miss Marple so let me know what
you prefer would you rather see Emily
Blunt as Miss Marvel and the Marvel
Universe or would you rather see her in
the Justice League franchise based on a
lot of the comments it seems like you
guys are more excited about a Miss
Marvel movie but now it's time to talk
about Lex Luthor one of the biggest
character changes happening in this
Batman vs. Superman movie is Jesse
Eisenberg's Lex Luthor whenever they
announced him for the role I feel like
everyone's brains just immediately went
to social network with capes some recent
production news kind of confirms that
lexcorp's gonna look a lot like Google
or Facebook like a really modern
hipstery office with super smart
intimidating people with really bad
social skills they are supposed to be
shooting a bunch of Lex Corp scenes on
June 11th and 12 so hopefully we'll see
some pictures from the set to confirm I
think the biggest secret right now is
whether or not Lex Luthor is gonna be
bald I'm not expecting him to be just
because I think it would look bad like
have you seen any of the Photoshop edits
of Jesse Eisenberg bald he does not look
better so now we need to ask this
question is this Superman sequel really
is Superman sequel or is it something
else personally I think that Batman vs
Superman stopped being a Man of Steel
sequel a long time ago the minute Warner
Brothers decided to recast Batman and
put him in the film it became a Justice
League world's finest movie they're not
saying that officially but whenever you
put all of the biggest Justice League
characters in the same movie it becomes
a Justice League movie whether you call
it that or not the movie is in
tended to lead directly into the Justice
League team up movie the title is even
dawn of justice so think of it as like a
prequel the only big things left to
reveal are which super villains are
gonna use in addition to Lex Luthor and
when all of the Justice League members
are gonna interact on screen at the same
time I know a lot of you are asking
about Stephen Amell and Grant Gustin
participating in all this new franchise
business and I don't think they're gonna
be in Batman vs Superman at all but
there is always the potential for them
to get really small cameos in the
Justice League movie I do think they're
fine just being on TV though I don't
think adding more characters to all
these new movies there's gonna make them
better but Stephen Amell did tease a
potential arrow movie once that series
is over I think there's gonna be at
least like five or six seasons of arrow
so that's a long way off but if you see
the energy and enthusiasm he has for the
role I definitely think he can last that
long that does become a problem for some
actors on shows that run past like eight
or nine seasons they just get really
burnt out that's one of the best things
about some of these DC Comics TV shows
the actors are so much more engaged with
us the audience then movie stars say
like Henry Cavill or Ben Affleck a lot
of that's just because of the secrecy
that surrounds movies but I really
consider TV to be the god of social
media I am really excited to see like a
TV version of Justice League happened
this fall between Grant Gustin and
Stephen Amell I think all you guys will
be really happy with the way those shows
work together unlike Batman and Superman
I consider the flash to be an official
member of team arrow so it's much more
of a partnership from the start
Batman from what I hear is gonna be very
mistrustful of Superman for most of that
new movie Zack Snyder pretty much killed
the idea of kryptonite in the first Man
of Steel movie so I'm really curious to
see how Batman deals with Superman the
first time they meet they're not gonna
be best buds and in the comics
Batman's kryptonite ring had always been
his insurance policy against the
Superman freakout but let me know in the
comments how do you think the Batman's
gonna deal with Superman personally I
think the only weakness that we saw in
that first movie is Kryptonian
atmosphere that's the only way to get
rid of his powers unless Batman got his
hands on some Kryptonian tech before
most of it got blown up or sucked into
the Phantom Zone so just to give you
guys a quick update on the videos that
are coming in the next couple of days
I'm working on a new Doctor Who series 8
video be sure to subscribe to get that
that's gonna post tomorrow hopefully
I'll have another Walking Dead bonus
video to post after that later tonight
I'll be posting my fault
start review be careful if you go to
that because you will cry a lot but
right now click here to learn more about
Emily Blunt being a badass and edge of
tomorrow and click here to learn more
about the new Justice League movie thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives